community brighton 8 news now is
sponsored by our community pride
partners finley automotive group
southwest medical part of optum care and
silver state schools credit union
southwest medical the sponsors of this
next segment are celebrating their 50th
anniversary and they're teaming up with
someone special to help celebrate check
it out
the year was 1972. the cost of gas was
36 cents a gallon elvis was the biggest
headliner in town and dr anthony marlin
started a small practice in las vegas in
1984 that practice was renamed southwest
medical associates this year marks their
50th anniversary and dr samuel bazan is
their senior medical director who has
been part of the group for the past 17
years over the years my roles have
changed and you know there's a lot of
things that have kept me at southwest
medical for all those years first of all
uh my patients i love my patients and
i you know it's just a i call this as a
real blessing for uh to have taken uh
care of these patients for over 17 years
some of those patients still continue to
see me to this day which is amazing you
know as a physician leader i actually
get to
do a lot more things for the
organization and enhancing the the
overall patient and staff and providing
experience and also creating programs
that make our improve the wellness and
lifestyle and and quality of lives of
our patients so i'm really proud of
those things as part of their 50th
anniversary southwest medical has
partnered with make-a-wish of southern
nevada here is scott rosenzweig
president of make-a-wish southern nevada
what a wish does is it creates an
environment for a kiddo to be a little
bit selfish think outside the box and
also dream about their future and when
you see a wish get granted it's like the
best thing in the world uh we had one
this saturday where a kiddo met a
youtuber they went shopping for lip balm
then they both made videos for their
youtube channels and truly holly our
wish kiddo has been looking forward to
this and during her treatment she would
watch videos of this youtuber so to her
it's not only meeting a celebrity but
it's a chance to get to meet somebody
who became a friend online to her and
she's been following for two years and
now she's in the driver's seat you've
got a big event coming up walk for
wishes the 20th anniversary tell us more
about the event and how can people
watching how can they get involved
so this is our largest community event
and it's one of our most fun events of
the entire year as you know jc because
you and mercedes have been around um
with us for a long time on this one but
really it's a 5k walk out at town square
saturday april 23rd registration starts
at 7 a.m 8 a.m is the start of the
programming it's a 5k fun run or walk we
don't time anything it's just an
opportunity for the community to come
out and support our wish kids get to
meet our wish kids and family and thanks
to that support we over the last 25
years at make-a-wish southern nevada
have granted over 2 300 wishes because
of community events like our walk for
wishes doc how special is his walk for
wishes to you and in your organization
so it's something very special for us
and i'm so proud that we're supporting
this organization and so please
everybody sign up april 23rd be there
sign up with your giving individually or
corporate
or volunteer or do whatever you can to
support this great program we've been
here for 50 years we're here for another
50 years great job
thank you to southwest medical for
sponsoring that segment walk for wishes
taking place at town square on april
23rd to register just go to wish.org
all right sally let's head over to